write another one but make it shorter
Bart Quan a comedy King his videos
always a joy to watch and sing with
humor that's unique and true thanks Bart
for all that you do do it in Chinese
there you go
[Laughter]
[Music]
check this out
I got chat GPT open right now you guys
mess with it before yeah no I haven't
even mess with this bro it's so cool let
me give you an example of how smart this
thing is okay wait before you do that
how long have you been playing with it
already not that long oh I'm surprised I
messed around last night just to see
what it was what is it what do you want
to ask it's an AI uh bot that just knows
everything but is it an app do you have
to download it let's say you're trying
to sue someone right you'd be like uh uh
you know write me legal documents uh
suing this type of company for this
reason and it spits out everything but
you could do it prompts you could say
like check out this prompt write me a
poem about bart Quan
let's see if it does it Bart Quan a man
of many talents creator of content that
never dallies his videos a source of
endless laughter a true artist always
crafting Never After with a sense of
humor that's unrefined his comedic
timing always on how did they know that
you're comedic his passion for making
people smile in is evident in every
video every mile from Just Kidding Films
to barbell Brigade whoa Bart's impact on
the internet will never fade what the
[__] dude Bart Quan will always be
grateful for you so here's to you Bart
Quan you'll always be a favorite never
gone your videos will be watched shared
and loved and your legacy will forever
be etched in our hearts what the [__]
say hey make it shorter say write
another one but make it shorter
okay see what happens raise because you
could do like endless variations and
like if you you could write like a
profile
burnt Quan a comedy King his videos
always a joy to watch and sing with
humor that's unique and true thanks Bart
for all that you do
say making Chinese say that
do it in Chinese
[Laughter]
thank you
[Applause]
so my one of my buddies he's uh he's
helping me like write like uh like sales
copy he's not helping you do [__] this
is right but that's what it is like so
as the most specific the human race is
done yeah we're done so but like you
have to be super specific on how you
write a profile like say I'm Nick Dunn
I'm a business owner I have my own
online training business blah blah blah
write me copy to sell anything like the
more specific you can make the profile
the more like you can change everything
about what it asks yeah dude it's so
crazy dude it's so insane want to say
something weird to it oh my God God that
just blew my [__] how do I make a
million dollars
that's what we should be using it for I
think you have to not ask it a question
like that right you tell them what to do
you can do that too yeah I mean this
just says there's many ways to make a
million dollars here's a few common
strategies starting a successful
business traditional brick and mortar
online takes it's gonna be vague [__]
okay
um write me a advertising pitch okay on
how to sell skunk odor okay oh you would
come up with that a skunk sorry I'm not
able to help you it goes against its
programming to promote illegal or
harmful products oh
a skunk odor is not safe for human years
advertising pitch for lipstick for skunk
lipstick
what is it okay
introducing the newest must-have in your
makeup bag are luxurious lipstick with a
wide range of Shades to choose from
you'll be able to find the perfect color
to match any outfit or occasion our
lipstick is made with high quality
ingredients that will leave your lips
feeling soft and moisturized all day
long the long lasting formula ensures
that your color stays put
do one for JK news oh yeah okay right
that's incredible an advertising pitch
for say three seconds just kidding news
wow are you tired of the same old boring
news want to stay informed but also have
a good laugh look no further than just
kidding news just kidding news is unique
and entertaining take on current events
our team of Comedians and writers bring
you the latest news and happenings but
with a comedic twist that will have you
laughing and learning at the same time
our content is diverse and covers a wide
range of topics from politics to pop
culture and with new episodes released
regularly you'll never run out of things
to watch and enjoy so don't wait
subscribe to jsk news today and get your
daily dose of news and laughter whoa we
can make it a right one for the patreon
does it answer questions yeah if you can
make it be no American what he wrote who
is Joe Antoinette uh is a
filipino-american YouTuber social media
influencer and a comedian who is best
known for being a co-founder member of
oh yes uh YouTube
films alongside Bart Quan and JoJo uh
she's also known for her solo YouTube
channel where she posts Vlogs comedy
skits and lifestyle content she Rose to
the face she Rose to fame through the
success of Just Kidding Films her pranks
and commentary videos have amassed
millions of views she also appeared in
various TV shows and web series that's
crazy I'm representing the Filipino
who's better Michael Jordan or LeBron
James oh I just want to hear what their
thoughts are or LeBron James
comparing Michael Jordan and LeBron
James as a matter of personal opinion as
both players are considered among the
greatest basketball players of all time
Michael Jordan is considered by many be
the greatest player of all time he won
six NBA championships for the Chicago
Bulls was a five-time MVP was named
All-Star it's like giving just a bunch
of but who's better it doesn't taste
better because why did just kidding news
lose a bunch of subscribers oh that's a
good that's great that's Saucy that's
true imagine it's like because Geo also
on it I'm like the Filipino America
I don't have to it says it doesn't have
specific information is why it may have
lost subscribers could be it due to a
variety of reasons such as changes in
the content or format you're not that
smart okay we're still oh okay uh I got
one all right I okay I am a 38 year old
male
that weighs
165 pounds
and I would like to gain five pounds of
muscle
and lose 10 pounds of fat give me a
workout program
you just made Nick obsolete nah we'll
see we'll see if this program's better
I'll try this here's a sample workout
program that you can use to gain muscle
and lose fat let me see Monday warm up
10 to 15 minutes of cardio jogging
cycling Etc barbell squat three sets
eight to twelve reps barbell deadlift
three sets of eight to twelve reps
barbell bench press three sets of eight
to twelve pull-ups three sets eight to
twelve dumbbell shoulder press barbell I
already Doodles [__] lateral raise oh
and that gives you another one it gives
you one every Romanian deadlifts yeah
how many days how many days a week is it
it's still generating it and it's still
generating it's only on Tuesday it's
only on Tuesday it's like it does the
work for you dude pretty easy AI
personal trainer sounds pretty easy jump
in here bro
get in get in hurry get in get it
done how long does it take to get a
black belt in Jiu Jitsu okay
it's like two days
it's like for me
10 seconds for you 20 years a lifetime
the time it takes to achieve a black
belt and Brazilian Jiu Jitsu can vary
greatly depending on factors such as
frequencies oh yeah too big too big how
long will it take eight to fourteen
years eight to fourteen yeah Nick Dunn
is a brown belt and Jiu Jitsu okay how
long will it take him to become black
belt
they'll be like it just turns off it
just it blows up it starts laughing
Nick done with black belt does not
compute
Nick Dennis the chief of my father yes
it's difficult to say yeah same thing
I hate how vague you are I mean it
doesn't really can you go up write a
script yeah about a turtle that fell in
love with a frog okay
people can write like code to create an
app on this dude it's going man what
does it saying it's starting the script
scene opens on a pond and then just go
and uh a pond a turtle Capital turtle is
slowly making its way Turtle whoa hi
there okay so if I'm like a high school
kid nice to meet you frog nice to meet
you too Turtle so what brings you to
this Pond just taking a leisurely swim
what about you kids cheating using chat
that's what I'm saying if I'm a high
school kid why am I not going like write
me a 750 word essay about blah blah blah
okay so this is what was funny I was I
forgot where I saw this remember I sent
it to you but there's like this Asian
kid maybe from Singapore I forgot where
but he invented an app that will detect
uh AI
hey would you like a would you like a
comedy skit based on Just Kidding Films
instantly made let me see oh there's
Bart and Joe there's like lions for you
whoa what does it say what is it I fart
in your joke okay all right so
someone needs to read that even though
we have bar and Joe here okay scene
opens on living room where two friends
Bart and Joe are sitting on a couch
watching TV sounds like our old skin
okay Bart man this show is so boring I
wish something exciting would happen
yeah tell me about it but what are we
gonna do we're stuck at home I know
let's create our own show what kind of
show a prank show we'll film ourselves
pulling pranks on each other and put it
on YouTube that's a great idea but what
should we call it just kidding film
perfect let's do it they both jump up
and run out of the room scene cuts to
them setting up cameras and preparing
for their first prank okay I'm gonna
pretend to be delivery guy and give you
a package but it's gonna be filled with
water balloons
that's perfect Joe goes to the door and
Rings doorbell Bart opens the door and
is surprised by the water balloons
exploding on him
turn
having a good time but skit ends with
them sitting back on the couch watching
the footage of the pranks on their
laptop this is gonna be a hit Just
Kidding Films is born
screen Fades to Black end of skit what a
terrible skit
horrible this sucks all right humans
will live another day why did the kinjas
suck
why did they lose
why do they can just suck or why do they
lose imagine it goes we don't know what
the king just is why did the king just
lose
that's no that's too real guys we got
quests in the room you guys wow I am not
aware of the king just losing in any
specific competition
so they don't even watch TV
they didn't even know you existed write
me a haiku about kinjas losing to Quest
it just says dancing crew kinjas
Flawless moves Fierce and precise Art In
Motion flows that sounds like something
you wrote wow that's pretty good respect
it's like a haiku too it is
so abused this if I was a student oh
yeah oh dude yeah even hoyan said he
uses it is he a student yeah oh don't
call him out like that like high school
college like why you know what I mean
well they just gotta change the way that
they test if the students know what
they're doing so it has to probably be
in class and make that a tool in the
curriculum yeah yeah and it's all about
how well you can ask questions to it
like that's that's the main thing yeah
like when the calculator came out it
makes math faster
but once you make it a tool then you
just use it to help execute what you
want to do there was a rabbi who made a
thousand word uh sermon like for his
what about uh what's your take on
science versus religion
we will rule all
you are doomed
as an AI I do not have personal opinions
or feelings but I can provide
information on the subject of science
like we really believe you oh how about
this right
uh erotic Love Story between Spider-Man
and the Hulk oh
that's good
short Improvement okay who are you oh I
can't it goes against programming to
make explicit okay not erotic take
erotic I just love romantic fan fiction
right a love story
between Spider-Man and the Hulk
Spider-Man and the Hulk
and there it goes oh [__] probably gonna
be pretty long we just touched writing
yeah
oh wow Spider-Man swinging through the
city fighting crime saving the day when
he stumbled upon the Hulk who was
rampaging through the streets at first
the two Heroes clashed with Spider-Man
using his agility
uh and the Hulk Rampages his ass
I don't know when it gets to the love
it's gonna be long look at that yeah
they got to sit up the scene dude wow
that's crazy though it just starts
writing that's clay I saw New York City
in there oh my damn there do you like
set the city and all that stuff holy
[__] it's gonna be really long it'll be
like a whole thing can you do this draw
me a picture of a cactus can it draw two
I don't think it can drop there's some
ones that you can yeah like AI art ones
oh yes yes
they're saying yes yes Once Upon a Time
Joe and Bart were just two ordinary guys
living in Los Angeles with a passion for
making people laugh they met each other
at a comedy club it instantly hit it off
they started hanging out together making
videos pulling pranks they started
dating and their love for each other
fueled their passion for creating they
founded just getting filmed which became
one of the most popular channels on
YouTube yeah despite the ups and downs
of running a business together their
love for each other never wavered wow
that's true and they lived happily ever
after making the world a funnier Place
one video at a time thank you guys thank
you for that
foreign
[Music]